el gobierno en un anuncio sin
precedentes acaba de destrozar
prácticamente el plan financiero que la
primera ministra listas había presentado
Hace tres semanas en un hecho como les
digo sin precedentes en todo el drama
político que hemos visto en los últimos
meses en este país el ministro de
finanzas recientes ignado Jeremy Hunt ha
presentado entonces las modificaciones
esenciales el programa bandera que era
un tipo de subsidio para ayudar a las
familias a sortear el incremento en las
facturas de la energía entonces acaba
también de ser modificado el gobierno ha
dicho que solo en el invierno de este
año podrá asumir ese costo adicional
pero para el 2024 tendrá que hacerlo el
2023 y el 2024 entonces tendrá que
hacerlo ya la población en general y lo
cierto Es que obviamente esta decisión
Tiene efectos políticos bien complejos